so it's really a
you know very appropriate panel we we
have for this um you know approaching
this from various points of view so
there's
alkali from microsoft research um
uh jal has been on this actually all all
three have been on panels before but
i'll just do a brief introduction yao uh
of course has a lot of work on delegated
computation and
interactive proofs
interactive proofs for muggles etc
we know
is um is at mit and he's worked
extensively on lwe uh leakage with
resilience and
other things uh actually ireland the
node recently had this uh very nice
paper on quantum advantage from any
non-local game
and
then we have uh thomas vidic from
caltech you know who's worked on
almost every aspect of
of this that you can think of from
verifiable proofs of quantumness to
certified randomness and mit star equal
re
so it would be great to hear um okay so
i think there were there were a lot of
very nice ideas and what mark was
speaking about uh
both from the point of view of
of
of proofs of quantumness and certifiable
randomness and you know teasing apart
just uh
um
you know where these ideas go but but
also just in terms of you know it's a
it's it's teasing out this piece from
maybe going back to reggae but but this
nice algorithmic piece that
we can just view as pure algorithms so
you know i'd love to hear
what each of you has to say about
about this to begin with
maybe i start since i haven't spoken yet
um so thanks mark for the for the great
talk um maybe even more for the great
result
um
sorry i think there's something wrong
with my audio
okay
um okay so maybe i'll keep it keep it
short okay one thing that um
that i realized when you were talking is
fascinating is that we now have a way to
set uh some kind of a benchmark for
uh you know quantum computational
advantage or something so you can fix
sha as you said and you could just fix a
code
um and you can have different sizes
maybe for the code um and that's it
right the first person who produces a
string that that satisfies the
the sha condition and that lies in the
code um has demonstrated that they have
a chrome computer so you can imagine a
sequence of challenges like this uh
they'll have done even more they have
they have generated a randomness string
a random string
oh
oh god okay sorry just one sec
the universal problem is
yeah i was traveling okay um okay so so
then i i like mostly i have a lot of
questions i guess you can just say a
couple questions i don't expect them to
be answered well i just i'll just bring
them up um so one is regarding the code
so because you title the paper um you
know the structure and so you focus on
the random oracle and you argued why why
that doesn't count as structure
and then the other side is is the code
which has many requirements and we're
talking about them at the end of the
talk and kind of in the spirit of what
umesh was bringing up i think it might
be worth trying to
bring these down as much as possible and
understand
what exactly is needed
you know maybe forget about codes maybe
maybe just talk about
a function or subspace or something and
what are um i know if it's possible to
think about it geometrically so in terms
of regard reduction there's some very
nice geometric pictures that you can
draw and you and you tried the same for
the code but somehow it was
i felt that the intrusion was not or at
least i i didn't okay so i thought that
that might be something interesting to
look at
um and then i want to pick up so so the
the randomness part so i um
i probably you thought about this i i
find that part slightly unsatisfactory
in the sense that uh because of the
ironstone and venus conjecture so in the
so what you give is really a generic
argument that says that uh if you have a
proof of quantumness
non-interactive like you describe it
um
okay not completely generic but almost
generic and the iron sun and venus
conjecture is true then you can
transform it into a non-interactive
proof of randomness at least you know
for the right kinds of adversaries
um
and
but you know okay i
i you really don't i think you don't
want to use that conjecture and so
certainly um
it it it it would it would be good to
try to figure out if uh for the for the
particular problem that you look at you
can
so i guess because you you cast i guess
you this is something you tried maybe
and it just didn't work out um
um yeah i mean i won't i wouldn't say
that we tried
super hard but uh
yeah it wasn't obvious to us how to
um remove the conjecture
um or even how to like you know approach
the problem in a way that didn't involve
resolving the conjecture
and then beyond that then the last thing
i'll say maybe is is
it's you um
you know for the other protocol like the
things that we worked on with with blue
mesh and some other protocols you have a
whole heraki of things that you can do
starting from the proof of quantumness
um including sometimes in the random
oracle so for example this this paper
with zika who i saw here and uh
where we we analyzed the protocol in
random vocals and there there's a public
key assumption
but we can say a little bit more things
we can say proof of quantities we can
say randomness we can also analyze
quantum improvers in the in the quantum
random oracle model and and argue that
they must have prepared the correct kind
of states etc and then you can and then
you can build up and so i thought that's
that's that's really something that
would be interesting to look at moving
forward from from what you did if you
can uh also understand what the quantum
improver does and start putting your
hands on on right on that
um
okay so i'll um um
pass it along and we can we can we can
circle back i think
actually sorry this so before we move on
um
um
um
in in terms of looking into the into
what the quantum program is doing and
constraining the content prover so um
[Music]
uh did
you know what's what's the
is there um
you know what's the what's the handle
into that that one might one might look
for here
is that is that clear even um
um i i i don't know actually um
you know basically
um
you know like
proving classical hardness we we can do
by drawing this connection to the the
coding
problem um
everything becomes much harder quantumly
though
so one thing you could try so you know
that they must have created
exponentially many points somehow
because otherwise you run into the
classical lower bound yes so that that's
already something so you might be able
to say okay they have some large
you know in the two to one examples this
is what you say you say they must have
created two points
um but they couldn't have done it
sequentially otherwise they would have
broken the problem and so they have a
superposition and so they you know
right
okay sorry
you know that's
we should think about this offline uh
yeah yeah we wanted to
yeah i i yeah i wanted to actually talk
a little more high level about this area
that your work lies in and to understand
what are uh
i guess make uh organized because in my
head it's a bit it's a bit of a messy
area in this
i mean all those also beautiful but kind
of putting them together understanding
the uh benefits of each one is a bit
mess in my head in the in the following
sense
so you know you want to essentially
separate quantum and classical in a
verifiable way you want to verify that a
quantum computer is doing something
classical
and now there's many things there's one
it seems like the one you're focusing
today is the assumptions you want
minimal assumptions or some
non-structured assumptions one is you
are you doing interactive versus
non-interactive can you is you're like
an np like you you give in your talk
versus like an attractive solutions like
in the work of uh
you know uh
you know this uh i remember all the
initials but you know the first kind of
paper on this um
we're not the first but hey okay then
there's a question of lately there's
been questions i've seen papers talking
about simplicity they want it to be as
easy as possible on the quantum computer
so that you can actually demonstrate it
so i feel like there's many many
a
you know uh axis that people are
interested in and i wondered like
how should we think of like what are the
import is there any
what are the actual things we should you
know someone who's coming comes to this
area what or wants to talk you know
do research in this
what are the important access what are
the lessons for are they all equally
important like
i i mean i think that's sort of a
central question in computer science
generally right uh you know we face this
kind of the same thing in crypto
generally where
uh you know there's important questions
in theory that are sort of far removed
from practice there's the important
practical questions um
you know maybe maybe in crypto we have
efficient uh protocols now so maybe the
like achieving
uh faster protocols is less important
but um i i guess i i would be of the
position that they're they're they're
all important questions
um we want to understand the assumptions
better we want to understand whether we
can
you know do it on
um
you know noisy quantum computers
we want to understand if it's relevant
for np problems or just interactive
problems i think these are all very
important questions okay so for example
if one could do uh let's say using
traction but to get like
a separation using symmetric
cryptography then you would be are you
are you gonna be thrilled you know what
i mean
you mean like based on one-way functions
or something as opposed to needing an
oracle exactly right i i think that
would be very
neat results
okay
although you could argue about the
interaction right i mean one thing that
i really like in mark's result is that
like from the point of view of doing
an experiment or a demonstration
interaction is it's hard experimentally
and also
you kind of need to be there right you
need to see it in action and so that
that's some kind of trust that you're
placing the sampling experiments and and
the thing that mark presented
um the fact that they don't have
interaction and that access so i agree
with you there's many different axes and
you have to decide which ones you favor
but in the axis of uh
kind of practicality or demonstrations
then interaction is a bit of a loss
but they would be good in the axis of
assumptions like you were saying just
just private key and that yeah
so so mark actually um following up on
what yeah was asking is if um
uh you know if you wanted to
replace um
uh replace the random oracle with this
with a specific uh function
is is it plausible that that there
there would be a hardness proof you know
under some assumption right so under
some standardized assumption i don't
think so actually um and the reason is
that you know the way we prove security
and cryptography is
by by a reduction and our reductions um
usually treat the adversary as a black
box and kind of ignore the computational
model
um
so
there is an exception which is when you
have an interaction
um and this is sort of exactly where the
lw proof of quantum is uh you know why
why why it's interactive and why it
works um
but if you're in the non-interactive
setting
uh basically
our our proofs technique our proof
techniques that we have don't care
whether the adversary is classical or
quantum so if you had a proof of
security
for classical adversaries it would also
work for quantum adversaries
so basically it means that you need to
start from a problem that's any way
you know classically hardware quantum
easy
sorry we can't tell you with that yeah
so misread my mind uh you know this is
exactly the question i i had for you so
so you're saying if suppose there is a
proof that um uh you know
of is an instantiation of the oracle
let's say sha and the proof that uh if
the classical algorithm succeeds then
you find collisions in char right and
you're saying right that means you have
a quantum algorithm to find collisions
in shop
at least using the you know the
techniques that we we have um you know
maybe there could be some crazy
proof that makes non-black box use of
the algorithm
let's say black box reductions for a
moment yes
so so it comes across to me that in a
funny way your result is a random oracle
uninstantiability result in this sort of
weird sense right uh in a way yes except
it could be that you can instantiate
this oracle under the hardness of
factoring and there is no contradiction
right i mean you would get right a
factoring algorithm and but then you
could ask okay why is this doing why are
you doing any better than actually
asking the quantum
computer to factor numbers right
but imagine the following possibility
and i want to know what you think um
let's say the reduction from you know
solving this problem classically to
factoring factoring to solving this
problem classically is adaptive it makes
many queries to the uh to the oracle
it's a huge number of queries to the
oracle
you know then you would get a
quantum algorithm for factoring that
invokes this article many many times
right this is a you know like so it
would be a circuit for for factoring uh
you know which which uses like n times
this oracle
and and perhaps this is you know just as
big as short circuit which is size n
squared or something like that and
square n cubed or something like that
right
but the the the classical algorithm
the the sort of the quantum algorithm
that actually solves this problem right
that's what you're plugging in
could actually be much smaller than the
short circuit
am i making sense so so you could
actually achieve quantum completeness
using a circuit
that is a lot smaller than the short
circuit and get a reduction
to the hardness of factoring while
you know not breaking any uh sort of uh
barriers
i see
i mean that would be a better
demonstration of quantumness and this
better than actually asking the quantum
computer to factor because it would be a
smaller circuit somehow
um
i mean yeah yeah that's a possibility i
i don't have any uh guess as to if
that's likely or not but
uh
yeah um but sort of you know it comes
across as strange to me that uh
you know you cannot possibly instantiate
this oracle and come up with a proof
under lwe or
or shah you know unless these problems
are themselves quantum easy but somehow
you'd find an instantiation based on the
hardness of factoring you know
right very odd uh
very out to me certainly
yeah
makes the result even more
intriguing you know
yeah and i guess i'll just say since it
was uh not exactly brought up but um
uh you know in terms of like actual
practical demonstrations of quantum
advantage it's unclear if our
construction makes any progress
there um
you know the the tools are
the tools are classically very efficient
right um you know it's basically list
decoding algorithms and and hash
function evaluations but
i think even that is
um sort of like
hopelessly beyond the scale of current
uh
current noisy quantum computers
um even just the hash function i i
didn't do a deep dive into the the
literature but what i could pull up
seems to
say that even evaluating sha requires
you know hundreds of thousands of
quantum
gates um
but you don't need shop right i mean you
could you're right right so there's
potentially room for improvement there
the thing i'm more concerned about is
the decoding algorithm while while not
too
well not necessarily too inefficient
um
you know you're you have to solve some
big linear system and then you have to
that the solution corresponds to a
polynomial that you then have to factor
um
like these things
you know
i'm not an expert in in uh implementing
uh
uh classical algorithms as quantum
circuits but they they strike me as
things that are you know very sensitive
to noise and um
you know unlikely to be
[Music]
you know easily implemented
but who knows
can i ask a question
oh yes please yeah
so um
you're saying that to implement child
like quantum circuit would be
kind of stupid because it would be much
more inefficient than doing it
classically
is there a proposal out there for hash
function
which is
the kind that was easy to implement or
like nicer to implement on the quantum
circuits and still seems to avoid in the
same way with the chi is not because
it's
based on some nice algebraic problem or
geometric but because of some set of
principles that people come up with
like they did when they did with sean
yeah i'm not aware of any i mean i guess
the the motivation is
has maybe not been there uh you know in
general you you know you you would like
it if your hash functions couldn't be
implemented on a quantum computer so
that you can't turn grover's algorithm
um
the motivation is that if you want to do
a post quantum photography you want a
hash function
but you don't if it's possible
right yeah certainly you know look if
you want if you want to implement your
cryptography on a quantum computer you
will need a compatible hash function
uh but right now we're sort of more
generally more worried about
the cryptography that's running on our
classical computers and whether the the
attacker with a quantum computer can
break it
um
and there there's just a lot less
motivation
to design a hash function that's
compatible with the quantum computer um
but the short answer is no i i don't
know if anyone has has has tried to do
this um
i think what
means i think what traffic does not post
quantum she means post post kind of when
everyone has a [ __ ]
no good answer but still i i think that
interestingly for classical cryptography
designing these hash functions was
i was before public photography that was
the basic thing that you started with
you know coming up with some str some
beast which seems to be hard and
still is a hard
i i i think it's a very well taken point
that
not supposed quantum cryptography but
for proofs of quantumness and things
like this it's it's a it's a good
challenge to think of
right hash functions which are optimized
not for classical computers but for
implementation on common computers
yeah so for example you you could think
about hash functions that are computable
in parallel uh right um you know uh very
well think about those you know gold
racks function and modify it somehow
right right
and i guess the other barrier is uh list
decoding right uh um
yeah and i think that's the worst the
harder of the two
uh that'd be my guess
is it
uh again i don't know if actually depth
is you know low depth kind of
implementations would make it more
amenable to
sort of near-term demonstrations um by
the experts
um
so then i guess the other barrier is
coming up with a parallel decoder right
list decoder
is there a reason it should not uh such
things should not exist um
i mean this is far outside uh
my my expertise
um
[Music]
i mean so so the you know the high level
blueprint of these decoders right is you
you solve some system of linear
equations and then and then you
interpret the solution as a polynomial
that you then factor
um
and
i
i guess it's
you know
i i actually have no idea what the like
you know like the depth complexity of
these algorithms is the first step maybe
it could be parallelized
right but i i don't know about the
factoring step
no idea
right um
[Music]
but you don't necessarily need to read
solvent codes right i mean that's just
one thing that worked for example sort
of
i don't know ldpc codes or something
that it doesn't seem like the
constraints of the problem are so bad
that you you really are forced to look
at right right so yeah there's a lot of
flexibility in the
you know in the code you just need you
just need to ensure these two properties
um it's information theoretically list
recoverable and then the dual is
uh
efficiently list decodable
um
and and i guess you know the implication
there also is you need a linear code
right
yeah
and yeah so the you know
i you know we
we sort of stopped when we found the a
code that satisfied these constraints
i'm not sure
a lot
a lot of people have been motivated to
find codes that have nice uh
decoding properties in both the primal
and the dual code
um
and so
you know maybe there just hasn't been a
lot of literature
um
you know trying to explore such codes
i guess they come up in quantum era
correcting codes right you look for both
yeah
um
um
yeah so so i guess
you know can you can you sort of explain
where the quantum advantage here comes
from i mean you know there are you know
uh in the
in the in the
in the old sort of non-local games where
thinking about it comes from
entanglement right and the sort of the
bcmv type things it comes from
non-rewind ability right um
can you sort of point to uh sort of a
feature of uh
you know quantum well i mean i guess the
way i would think about it is you know
so so one thing you can do with a
quantum computer is you can you know
generate a uniform superposition
and then query it on a random oracle
that has one bit outputs and measure the
measure the result and what you get is a
a uniform superposition
of right and and uh maybe until recently
it wasn't clear what uh what what's the
point of doing this what
does such a state have any any advantage
over
you know just sampling a random
classical value
and maybe the the first hint of of
progress was the the sort of the
follow-up work to the original um
you know uh proof of quantumness from
lwe that simplify things using using
random oracles
and they're
um
you know
they're also using a one bit oracle and
um
you know you can sort of interpret what
they showed is that in
you know at least assuming lwe in a
computational setting
uh you actually do get something special
um when you have this quantum
superposition of inputs of a one bit
random oracle
um
and and you know our our result
sort of saying that in a different way
right that's interesting uh it's very
interesting
huh
right and i guess at sort of a at a low
level
what what's special about this quantum
state is that if you apply the quantum
fourier transform you get something that
has uh you know that's concentrated
around zero
whereas with if you just had a classical
string and you apply the fourier
transform you get a random string
and that's kind of like the low level
you know concrete feature that we take
advantage of
right
[Music]
that's really interesting
well if we if we back out even further
then it seems like
in in some sense
you know if you look at what what
regal was uh originally trying to do
was uh was to come up with a with a
quantum algorithm for
uh for shortest lattice factor
right and um
or finding a short vector
and uh
and of course there was this one step
that uh
you know that that he couldn't really do
and so that that became lwe right so
instead of instead of showing giving and
giving an algorithm it ended up saying
that that there was this hard problem
and
um
and with a quantum reduction showing
that it was a hard problem
and so so in a sense uh what you've done
is you've sort of massaged that
that with these new insights as you as
you're pointing out and and uh
um
gone back to saying well
uh
to finishing up that goal of saying
here's something for which you can use
this approach to give a give an
efficient quantum algorithm
right exactly
it's a very nice way to put it yeah
that's very nice
um
do you so so this so there is this new
algorithmic technique here right in this
multiplying quantum states do you see
sort of
um
other other applications of it beyond
sort of i i i know you have all these
sort of applications of uh for
randomness generation
and down the line the questions where
can you
sort of um
do verification in general right uh
computational application in general
but the technique itself
you know seems very uh very novel you
know um um
sort of an open-ended question you know
uh
are you referring to the like the
application or the abstraction of rego
for
or like the particular setting with the
the random oracle's corresponding let's
say
yeah let's say with the particular
setting so this is a sort of a framework
like omesh said to make the odd
reduction into not a reduction but an
algorithm right right right
so that's a new algorithmic sort of tool
in the in the toolkit
now
um
um
yeah
do you do you envision sort of
applications beyond sort of the obvious
uh
in a sense right uh which
yeah um
yeah i don't know i mean i guess there's
a there's a question of um
if this could be used for
you know name some
you know
uh quantum cryptographic object that
that people want to build
um
you know if it's uh
you know or like what what um
was mentioned earlier about um
you know actually characterizing what
what the quantum computer is doing as
opposed to just verifying this quantum
so that's kind of one
uh you know maybe the
like most natural thing to think about
next
yeah
or
um yeah can you do
uh
yeah i guess what like what what quantum
protocols could could something like
this enable um
uh mark um the longest line like
uh have you thought about like potential
connections between this and quantum
lightning like they they're you're in
your approach you're doing kind of money
like the yeah yeah yeah
right that you have these like super
positions that okay in this case it's
it's clearly not money right away
because any quantum computer can just
generate this but you can imagine like
maybe there's like some hidden way to
generate the state once and like if i
give it to you
like generated with some secret value
that like maybe somebody else can't
generate it again now
right right um because yeah it's
verifiable right so that's like the key
thing that makes it
exactly
so um
so so a problem that i i've like to
to advertise to people um
is is sort of back in regex version
um
the question is
can you
uh can you come up with a
you know a a setting like rego but where
the
so reggae showed that search lwe
is hard if you assume cis
is is hard
um
the question is what about decision lwe
now for
for random for for a you know a random
linear space search and decision or
equivalent
but you could have a structured version
um
and and right the reg of reduction
preserves any structure right if you
your
if your sis instance is
uh if your particular class assist
instances is hard you get the
corresponding lwe search problem is hard
but maybe that search problem for some
particular subspaces maybe the maybe the
decision problem for some particular
subspace actually becomes easy
um and if you had that actually
um you probably would get uh
you know quantum lightning or more
specifically quantum money um basically
the
ability to do the decision
uh
the decision problem allows you to like
verify
um whereas but the
like to actually construct the state you
need the ability to do search
um
and and mark one second so you're saying
for random
lwe with random matrices you're saying
there is a reduction from
search to decision yes
right so we we don't expect uh
this you know we don't expect decision
ld to be easy on a random for a random
matrix
right
that's what you mean but maybe maybe
there's a matrix that has some you know
nice structure to it that'll make the
decision version easy yeah um you know
you know and sort of like
switching back to the top click of this
paper we showed a particular
uh matrix namely the ones coming from
these error correcting codes that
and we also changed the metric um you
know from l2 norm to this you know this
oracle thing
um
but
right it's the
you know i guess what you would want for
a quantum money quantum lightning kind
of result is something where
the search problem is actually hard
because that's what you need to actually
you know go through the whole algorithm
but you still want the decision version
to be easy so that you
can you can still get the verification
[Music]
that's great um
uh any anything any other final thoughts
so
questions
well thanks again thank you mark for
thank you for having me thanks to the
panel for
really lovely comments
so we'll see you next week
amazing thank you very much thank you